sie haben heute sogar eine Gemeinsamkeit
würde ich fast sagen mit Herr stöckeln
ich bin ja sehr gespannt und die These
die sie mitgebracht haben und ich meine
die ist ja eigentlich auch gegen
Mittelmäßigkeit oder oder dafür dass wir
sie wieder haben wie also ich sag's dir
mal Deutschland wird ja auch wieder ein
bisschen spießiger und ähm wir werden
hier sehr dominiert von von so auch von
unserem Alltags Spiel Sichtum und auch
wir haben immer mehr Leute was ich auch
feststelle die sehr angepasst sind und
bloß nicht auffallen um Gottes Willen
und alles geht so ein bisschen zurück
also wenn ich mir überlege als ich
anfing als als junges Mädchen als ich
bin immer noch sehr jung da war es ja so
da waren die Leute viel offener viel
lustiger ich habe ganz andere Leute auch
in meinem Geschäft getroffen also es
wird alles ein bisschen zurück und ich
glaube wir waren unsere Zeit schon mal
viel weiter voraus und sind jetzt wieder
so ein bisschen wir kommen wieder zurück
also wir entwickeln uns ein bisschen in
eine Zeit zurück von der ich glaube na
ja das haben wir eigentlich alles schon
überschritten und ich finde und das ist
eigentlich etwas wichtig finde dass die
Leute bisschen mehr Mut wieder haben
sollen in der Gesellschaft einfach auch
das zu machen was sie wirklich wollen
und sich nicht an jede Sache immer
anzupassen und ich will ein Beispiel
sagen wenn ich zum Beispiel ich meine
ich habe ja ein relativ einfachen Look
und es ist ja überhaupt nicht auffällig
und auch fast spießig so wenn ich
irgendwo abends hingehe auf
Abendveranstaltungen so und du siehst
200 Männer in Anzügen ich falle immer
noch auf
2022 die Leute denken na ja der lustige
sprechende Torwand was ist der
eigentlich und man glaubt sofort in
Deutschland
für Deutschland nein ich glaube aber zum
Beispiel und ich war letztens in München
bei einer Gala und habe den Raum
betreten ich war sehr schön das muss ich
dazu sagen du die Leute haben aufgehört
zu reden die haben mich angestanden oder
was ist das denn so also ich glaube dass
wir da wieder viel spießiger werden als
wir es mal waren
da fragen wir doch mal hier Herrn Kraus
ob er Badekappe oder Turbanisch
mit der Speisekarte in Deutschland keine
Vollverschleierung
ich will das jetzt noch mal anmerken ja
kein Problem
ich habe 50 torbanden
Angebot sehr gerne an in der nächsten
Sendung sitze ich auch die Macht eines
Sultans habe
der Look macht ja was mit dir du guckst
den Spiegel und denkst du ja ich bin ein
würdest du dann auch die Menschen dazu
auffordern mutig in anderen Bereichen
noch zu sein als der unbedingt und
unbedingt also ich finde an sich
ich merke oft ich das Beispiel jetzt
wirst du wahrscheinlich schreien gleich
weiter etwas sage der BR der
chaosflughafen schlechthin du stehst an
der Schlange es gibt ja es gibt tausend
andere so Stellen wo man sich anstellen
kann und dann sage ich vor mir steht ein
Mann und ich sagte dem Mann gehen sie
doch nach vorne da vorne diese junge die
ist frei guck mich an ne das mache ich
jetzt nicht ich sage aber das ist doch
frei dann bin ich über alle Gitter
gegangen und habe mich hingestellt alle
haben gestartet
dachten so wie das darf man doch jetzt
gar nicht machen wo ich so denke na ja
selbst schuld wer erwartet selbst schuld
wer erwartet ich bin vielpfleger ich
kann nicht warten ihm keine Zeit so
verstehst was ich meine oder was so
kompliziert
ja dann bin ich auch kein Spießer das
mache ich nämlich später
sehr gut ich frage mich und deshalb da
bin ich ganz bei ihm ob das der richtige
Ansatzpunkt ist für das Problem Spießer
oder nicht Spießer ich glaube auch das
Outfit ist sehr sekundär was das
betrifft also die eigentliche
Spießigkeit die ich auch so wie sie das
ist eher eine geistige verspießerheit
und ich sehe ich habe den Verdacht wir
waren Ewigkeiten nicht mehr so
konformistisch wie in den letzten Jahren
und das hängt wahrscheinlich jetzt
bringe ich auch mein Thema wieder unter
dieser mit dieser Angst zusammen dass
die Leute sich nicht mehr trauen das zu
sagen was sie denken dass auch zu tun
was sie für richtig halten weil sie
immer das Gefühl haben nicht nur soziale
Kontrolle sondern auch politischer Druck
der auf ihnen legt und das trauen sie
nicht also ich glaube wenn die Leute
alles so sehen aussehen würden wie Herr
kraus und ich im Anzug oder wie auch
immer das wäre nicht die Katastrophe die
am samstagkatastrophe ja
wow das ist schon Luxation
also das aber ich glaube wenn da liegt
das eigentliche Problem also wir sind
geistig sie haben
darunter leidet die Demokratie ja wenn
ich mir das anschaue sie haben diese
Untersuchungen noch besser im Kopf
Alsbach Studie wie viel Leute trauen
sich nicht mehr sagen was ist 60 Prozent
60%. ich lese im Moment ein Buch eines
ehemaligen spiegelredakteurs ein
falsches Wort Pfister
übersetzen also das weiß ich gerade noch
das Buch das Buch ist deshalb so toll ja
weil es nicht von dem Spiegel Redakteur
ist also der komplett links ist aber der
einfach sieht es ist ein derartiger
wahnsinn was da einfach war
correctness walkners das ist so
wahnsinnig dass selbst ich als Linker
sagen muss das geht nicht also dass man
dass das tolle Arbeiten
damit es klar ist da ist jetzt nicht das
Böse blöde ein Wort gemeint sondern es
sind relativ unverfängliche Begriffe
gemeint ja haben sie ein Beispiel
Indianer
Papa
Mensch mit Gebärmutter und Mensch mit
Prostata oder oder was weiß ich bestimmt
den Kreisen gut aber wenn sich das so
liegt die Wahrheit das ist EU-Politik
das ist EU-Politik da hat er leider war
etwas Wahres gesagt vieles von dem man
denkt das ist an verrückten Wolken
Universitäten der Fall das ist längst EU
Wirklichkeit in Spanien pro genitora pro
Genitiven Positionen gesellschaftlichen
Positionierung auch trotzdem sprechen
kannst du nur noch so sprechen die Folge
ist dass die Leute die Klappe halten
also Mama und Papa und die Folge
Demokratie das keine lebhafte Diskussion
mehr stattfindet auch in Kollegen
Kreisen nicht mehr ja ich habe Freunde
verloren aber gut könnte man sagen
schade darum weil ich bestimmte Dinge
angesprochen habe und viele andere gehen
in die innere Emigration sie können es
ablesen an der Wahlenthaltung
40 Prozent
wenn eines Tages nur noch 10% wählen ich
garantiere Ihnen ich muss lernen sich
trotzdem Parteien als Sieger der
Schlusswort gehört
also da muss ich sagen hat Herr Kraus
nicht recht wir sehen uns morgen abend
wieder nicht mit mir sondern mit meiner
Kollegin Felicia pochhamer bis morgen
Abend dann also tschüss schönen Abend
noch